la chronique culture du mercredi johan a
consacré ce soir par tabasse l'école du
spectacle équestre oui pour en parler
avec nous marine pensez vous nous avez
rejoint sur le plateau vous travaillez
donc à l'académie du spectacle équestre
bartabas aux grandes écuries du château
de versailles alors l'académie présente
deux fois par semaine un spectacle
équestre intitulé la voie de l'écuyer on
y retrouve des chevaux des écuyers bien
sûr mais pas seulement alors la
particularité de l'académie c'est de
former les écuyers à d'autres
disciplines artistiques comme le chant
la danse les scream le tir à l'arc
japonais le kyudo donc effectivement on
retrouve d'une façon ou d'une autre ces
disciplines dans le spectacle mais c'est
comme comme malade indique le nom c'est
une académie de spectacles et qu'est ce
donc ça ne se limite pas aux chevaux à
quel type de public s'adresse le
spectacle c'est plutôt pour les amateurs
les enfants les adultes c'est un verre à
tout sauf au camp même avoir certaines
connaissances quand même en équitation
pour le non je ne pense pas on le
conseille à partir de 5 ans puisqu'il ya
des moments très calme et donc il vaut
mieux éviter les tout petits mais non et
moi je ne suis pas cavalière et j'aime
beaucoup le spectacle donc voilà chacun
je prends je pense c'est un vrai fin
voilà c'est du spectacle après ce qu'ils
ont
qui font de l'équitation ont une vision
plus particulière mais je pense qu'il
s'adresse vraiment à tout le monde il me
le dit si justement à partir de 5 ans
pascal et moments de concentration ça
veut dire que ça peut perturber les
cavaliers par exemple l'organisation du
spectacle de oui parce qu'il ya des
moments vraiment en silence et si
effectivement faire tomber les chauvauds
exactement faut un certain calme dans
exactement donc les représentations ont
lieu les samedis à 18 heures et les
dimanches à 15h avec pendant les
vacances justement des représentations
spéciales supplémentaires tout à fait en
est hélas cet après midi ouvert au
public et puis maintenant jeudi prochain
le 8 novembre et puis pareil en décembre
on va faire des ouvertures sur
supplémentaires pendant les vacances le
27 décembre par exemple donc c'est il ya
ça c'est une des choses qu'on peut qu'on
peut faire donc voir le spectacle mais
pas seulement puisque on peut aussi voir
un petit peu les coulisses découvrir les
coulisses des grandes écuries avec
notamment
des séances de travail qui sont les
matinales tout à fait tous les matins
donc des jours où nous sommes ouverts au
public il ya un entraînement public des
écuyers voilà et puis que ce soit le
spectacle où la matinale en fait chaque
ouverture est suivie de la visite des
écuries et l'entraînement justement est
le même qu'il y ait ou non le public
vous vous adaptez un petit peu il ya une
petite mise en scène forcément il ya une
vétille la mise en scène mais c'est
voilà son voile et payet vous dévoilez
pas tous ses atouts même une part de
mystère aussi guillaume oui mais à
l'arrière fortement pendant la visite il
ya des choses plus détendue dans la
carrière de dans la carrière de travail
également donc après ya des choses qu'on
voit pas forcément comme les cours des
scream à tous les arts dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure ça on ne voit que
vraiment la partie avec les chevaux tout
à fait justement où l'académie là va
bientôt fêter ses 10 ans puisqu'elle a
ouvert en 2003 enfin 2002 les grandes
écuries de versailles était encore en
travaux et les premiers mois de
formation en fête était donnée
aubervilliers à l'époque bartabas
voulait mettre en place une académie à
l'image des centrica c'est à dire avec
une majorité de filles est ce que vous
vous avez connu que cette période ou pas
je ne les ai pas connu mais sinon
c'était pas une volonté de bartabas de
faire une équipe féminine il se trouve
que comme dans les centres équestres là
la présence des jeunes filles augmente
après du coup lors du recrutement on a
eu plus c'est une
plus de cavalière et des cuillères que
c'est intéressant ce que vous me dites
pas ce que nous avons rencontré emmanuel
dardenne qui lui a intégré donc l'école
elle déduit ouverture voilà aujourd'hui
il écrié titulaire et nous expliquer que
justement quand lui à postuler c'était
il y avait que des filles en fait quel
sens être acceptée je ne sais pas en
tout cas on va voir justement la
rencontre on a passé une matinée avec
lui à versailles on va manger à quoi
ressemble le quotidien d'un écuyer
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences emmanuel
dardenne qui centre analyse crime est en
fête écuyer l'escrim fait partie de sa
formation à l'académie du spectacle
équestre de bartabas un lieu prestigieux
qu'il a intégré dès son ouverture en
un jour j'ai entendu parler que leur
tabac créé une académie à versailles qui
recrutent et que des filles donc j'ai
quand même tenter ma chance j'étais
sélectionnée pour aller au bar grillé
pour pour passer les auditions et puis
ça s'est bien passé on peut dire des
manuels qu'il est né dans l'équitation
une passion héritée de son père vous
sortez de la maison je faisais 5 m
j'avais les écuries donc à trois mamies
à cheval et j'ai grandi à cheval court
j'ai jamais connu de poney toujours des
grands chevaux à auzat j'ai fait mon
premier spectacle la première
représentation en public avec mon papa
emmanuel a effectué son service
militaire à la guerre de républicaine de
paris et à continuer d'enchaîner les
spectacles avant de rejoindre les
grandes écuries de versailles aux côtés
de bartabas emmanuel est aujourd'hui
écuyer titulaire il côtoie des écuyers
confirmé qu'ils participent au spectacle
de bartabas depuis quelques années il
forme aussi des cavaliers en stage qui
intégreront le spectacle équestre après
un ou deux ans d'apprentissage on est
trois être là depuis le début il ya plus
d'un an avec l'or avec leurs grilles en
mana et coordinateur artistique et
pédagogique
c'est à dire qu'on va glacer tout du
spectacle en règle on voit quand ça va
pas les transferts de chevaux
concernant la dent prenez note une
journée type commence vers 7 heures
chaque écuyer dispose d'environ 4
chevaux ils sont une dizaine en tout à
se répartir 44 bête balade dans le parc
du château détente à la longe répétition
de chorégraphies ou exercice de dressage
chaque homme organise son travail avec
ses chevaux sur la semaine à savoir qui
a six jours il connaît un jour de repos
il ya six jours donc deux jours de
spectacle samedi dimanche doit il reste
quatre jours pour travailler le cheval
en dehors des spectacles il ya plus de
ça ils sont il faut suivre les cours à
l'académie on a des cours de kyudo c'est
du tir à l'arc du tir à l'arc japonais
avec un arc dissymétrique ajoutez à cela
les cours de chant d'escrimé artistique
de pilates et de danse ne l'oublions pas
il s'agit d'une académie de spectacles
équestres l'enseignement dispensé est
gratuit et chaque écuyer touche un
salaire les écrits par exemple à vienne
en autriche qui gagne je crois à 8000
euros par mois nous attend est bien loin
je dirais qu'un écrit en france
gagnante redire et 2000 euros et au
mieux 4 mire le gain ne constitue aucune
motivation est régulier c'est avant tout
comprendre et communiquer avec son
cheval mais c'est aussi mettre sa
passion au service de l'art et du
spectacle
entre les chorégraphies à deux chevaux à
3par ou ca
hamish vos chorégraphies des scream avec
six chevaux l'inter sans oublier les
solos au trot au galop et les combats
des scream la création de bartabas
intitulé la voie de l'écuyer est à
découvrir tous les samedis et dimanches
au projet curé de versailles
l'agent n'a pu suivre un homme donc
voilà au cours de ce reportage pourquoi
il ya plus de femmes alors parce que le
milieu équestre en france se féminise
énormément une explication
peut-être que comme c'est plus un loisir
voilà et puis il ya cette relation qui
se développe entre le cavalier et son
cheval peut-être que c'est plus féminin
et nous l'explication qu'on a pour
l'académie plus particulièrement c'est
cette ouverture à d'autres disciplines
artistiques un haut niveau on imagine
plutôt que les hommes vont vers de la
compétition voilà et que le pour le
spectacle et oui c'est bien
l'enseignement de la
plus ancienne et plus souple vous vous
êtes vous êtes adeptes aussi des chevaux
comment vous êtes arrivé l'académie
équestre et non moi je suis plutôt
adepte du spectacle vivant et pas du
tout des chevaux je me réadapte au fur
et à mesure avec eux nous avons eu une
plus tôt nous une relation compliquée
dans ma jeunesse avec des expériences ça
va mieux ça va beaucoup mieux et pour
mieux le soigner j'espère justement pas
en parlant des chevaux on a vu le cheval
donc de des manuels qui s'appelait
jéricho qui était un lusitanien donc à
un cheval portugais chaque race il ya
quatre races différentes 1 c'est ça et
chacune a des caractéristiques
particulières tout à fait alors même
dans le lusitanien la majorité à
l'académie sont des chevaux crème aux
yeux bleus ce qui est assez rare chez
les lusitaniens et d'une façon générale
les lusitaniens ont des capacités
pour le dressage classique donc voilà
pour les scream qu'on voit actuellement
c'est les criollo argentins qui sont
aussi des chevaux qui sont utilisés pour
le polo pour leur maniabilité et leur
réactivité du coup on peut mieux les
dresser en fait sans leur donner des
ordres avec une main c'est tout à fait
et puis là aux longues rênes ce sont des
petits chevaux aussi portugais les soria
et effectivement on utilise aussi des
quarters ce qu'ils sont des chevaux qui
ont la capacité de spleen et donc de
tourner sur eux-mêmes mais puis sont
très très vive très vive très très
énergiques aussi un les côtes horreur ça
oui oui nous nous on travaille plus sur
l'énergie avec les argentins mais
effectivement les coins de l'europe
peuvent aussi faire preuve de
beaucoup d'énergie ça veut dire savoir
de quoi vous parlez oui beaucoup
d'énergie pour ses chevaux oui oui donc
l'année prochaine vous fêterez des dix
ans de l'académie équestre de bartabas
est ce que des événements particuliers
sont prévus pour pour ses dix ans pour
cet anniversaire alors on travaille on
travaille à l'organisation de cette
année pour marquer vraiment pour
souffler nos dix bougies en beauté on
sait d'ores et déjà que nous serons
à la grande halle de la villette à paris
pour reprendre la création que nous
avons fait l'année dernière avec carolyn
carlson et 16 danseurs du centre
chorégraphique national de roubaix nord
pas de calais et nos écuyers voilà sur
des musiques de philip glass donc là
c'était vraiment comment en faire se
rencontrer des danseurs et nos écuyers
avec des notions qui ne connaissent rien
dans l'univers de chevaux de prime abord
non mais maintenant ça y est on a déjà
ne travaillait pas mal avec eux donc ça
ils commencent à se demander même après
la première la création il y en a qu'on
a accueilli qui sont venus pendant une
semaine s'occuper des funérailles qui
savait bien là s'il part dans plusieurs
représentations s'intéressera oui ce
n'est pas une représentation unique à ne
pas louper ah non non on avait alors
mais ce sera à ne pas louper quand voilà
on amène à la grande halle
et les
entraînements et les échauffements des
écuyers seront publiques sous le
péristyle de la grande halle enfin voila
c'est un vrai donc toutes les infos les
horaires pour visiter voir le spectacle
aux grandes écuries de versailles sont à
retrouver donc sur le site internet
www.balairatt.ch faire merci juin la
prochaine page culture mercredi prochain
merci également d'être venu nous parler
ensemble de cette académie équestre
bartabas à versailles on reste dans la
culture les sorties ciné à présent que
pensez-vous des films à l'affiché depuis
ce matin comme chaque mercredi et le dit
- et allez à votre rencontre à la sortie
des premières projections
c'est franck et de mounir il suscite un
chien son chien c'est ce par qui et
c'est bien parce qu'après il ya d autres
enfants qui veulent faire pareil avec
leurs animaux et il passe des trucs
bizarres mais j'aime bien tim burton et
tout donc je crois que c'était sympa
c'était original comme l'histoire
c'était mignon qui ça colle bien avec
halloween aussi donc c'est cool on était
un peu étonné on retrouve tim burton en
fait on retrouve bien tim burton et donc
n'a pas déçu du tout un peu déçu parce
que pendant tout le film se passe pas
grand chose quoi et bas tout est résumé
dans la faim en gros le film il était
bien il est effrayant beaucoup de
suspense sur un plan parfait
c'est une comédie agréable
quelques
gag un peu lourd parfois mais bon dans
l'ensemble très bon moment super
franchement les effets spéciaux enfin
tout je sais pas ce que tu en as pensé
quoi franchement c'était c'était très
bien stylé bien j'aime bien greg mais il
a pris un peu de longueur je trouve un
petit peu de l'action
apple longueur le dès le début et bien
pu employer à la présentation que tu as
peu long il était bien même si
l'actualité un peu longue mais il est
très bien moi j'ai retrouvé le james
bond que j'ai aimé voilà très bien un
très bon film excellent film on s'est
bien amusé c'était génial tout fut vite
et génial l'intriguent super
intéressante du début jusqu'à la fin
franchement génialissime
skyfall et après le cinéma si vous
souhaitez découvrir la région le guide
le petit futé vient de sortir un volume
consacré à la ville de versailles un
city guide compact à moins de 5 euros
vous découvrirez et qu'il n'ya pas que
le château a visité du quartier notre
dame et ses rues anciennes au quartier
saint louis et sa cathédrale en passant
par l'académie du spectacle équestre et
dont l'administratrice s'était
d'ailleurs avec nous il ya quelques
minutes sur ce plateau le city guides du
petit futé vous donnera bien sûr les
bonnes adresses pour se restaurer se
loger ou encore faire du shopping rester
bien avec nous le 7-8 se poursuit tout à
l'heure dans cette édition nous vous
donnerons aussi des idées de sorties
d'ailleurs à faire en famille durant la
seconde semaine de vacances de la
toussaint avec nos invités pour
l'instant les détails de cette décision
du conseil général des yvelines de
consacrer 100 millions d'euros au
collège et de miser sur le développement
est des tableaux numériques les
explications de valérie auribeau
en visite au collège jean philippe
rameau de versailles pour la fin des
travaux de reconstruction alain schmitt
président du conseil général des
yvelines a rappelé les actions du
département en faveur des collégiens une
priorité avec la sphère sociale au total
100 millions d'euros soit 10% du budget
du département sont alloués aux 115
collèges publics yvelinois
c'est pas une politique nouvelle qui est
mise en oeuvre mais c'est une politique
forte c'est 100 millions d'euros engagés
chaque année en faveur de la politique
patrimoniale des collèges et de tout ce
qu'on peut apporter comme assistance aux
collégiens en terme de transport en
termes de matériels informatiques mises
à la disposition car l'une des
spécificités des yvelines c'est
l'informatique et le haut débit le
département pionnier en la matière
compte 14 cents tableaux numériques
interactifs au sein des collèges dix
mille ordinateurs pour un investissement
de 1 million 800 mille euros les zones
d'éducation prioritaire ne sont pas
oubliés les collège de trappes ont
notamment été équipés en zone
d'éducation prioritaire bien entendu
c'est important nous apportons une un
supplément si vous voulez dead en
logistique de 25% par rapport à l'apport
classique pour un collège au prorata du
nombre bien sûr de collégiens mais là le
département pour ce qui est des zones
d'éducation prioritaires qui sont au
nombre de 18 il ya 18 collèges qui
s'entend en zep nous apportons 25% de
suppléments en termes d'équipement les
aides font aussi partie de ces collèges
dont les chiffres de la demi pension
sont en augmentation constante
aujourd'hui le département cherche à
harmoniser les tarifs des cinquante
mille repas servis chaque jour pour les
collégiens des collégiens qui voient
leur établissement réhabiliter ou
reconstruits d'année en année parmi les
115 collège 84 sont entièrement neuf
dernier en date le collège philippe de
champaigne du mesnil-saint-denis au sein
duquel une section pour malvoyants a été
aménagé d'équipements spécifiques